it's become the one thing that my whole
family hopes I leave to them an
estimated 20 million dollar estate at
state according to a petition filed
yesterday in LA Robin and his older
brother Brennan claimed Tonya Colo is
overreaching and extremely greedy the
brothers co-trustees of their dad's
living trusts say Tonya even threatened
to go to the tabloids if they didn't
succumb to her demand so what are her
so-called demands well Tanya allegedly
wants more than what was set out in the
trust and negotiated in her prenup with
Allen the legal documents claims she
inherited 25 percent of his personal
effects a $500,000 life-insurance policy
all of his death benefits from pensions
and Union memberships and 40% of Allen's
estate the other 60 to go to his sons
including 19 year old Carter the son he
raised with Tanya but now according to
Brennan and Robyn Tanya says she's owed
more than what's in the trust as for the
prenup they claim Tonya says it no
longer holds up because she had to forgo
opportunities to pursue and advance her
own career in order to support Allen and
be his companion and partner including
raising Carter but Brennan and Robyn say
the prenup is valid because she signed
it and the Trust is legally relevant
because their father updated it just 10
months before his death in a statement
to ET Canada Tanya's lawyer says it is
clear that Allen's sons have chosen this
distasteful public smear tactic to bully
Tanya by filing a bogus lawsuit and
refusing family mediation tanya is still
grieving the death of her beloved
husband and out of respect for Allen's
memory intends to handle his son's false
statements privately